I grew up in the Bill Nighy generation  so seeing the experiments being done in  learning science from demonstrations  that are very tactile and visual was  something that was very familiar to me  in high school biology and art were my  two favorite subjects and my degree is  in medical illustrations so I had half  my classes were science classes and half  our art classes we did cadaver  dissection and then we drew from it and  it was a real mixture of the science and  the art and and the best way to  communicate things and a lot of  illustration classes that were  non-medical because that teaches you  storytelling and Composition science  just excites me and I like being in a  position to teach it to others to  communicate it to others when I found  out about this profession it just  clicked so I went with it  and I'm glad that I did  you